devant diffusé aujourd'hui se trouve sur
far cry prime hall primat du tout comme
vous voulez et donc c'est à la passe à
la préhistoire et moi sommes scène
typique de far cry un clan se faire
exploser par un ours à l'eau va les
aider on est des héros ok je regrette le
regret c'est quoi sa valeur entre un ton
la vapeur et un ours
quel est cet animal même temps je me
sois je vous soyez au courant groupe
il est où on se fait défoncer d'entrée
dieu pourquoi j'ai fait ça en plus les
troyens qui l'habitait je devais débuter
c'est pas ils me font sourire sur la map
regardez pois rouges qui poursuit tu
m'auras pas
mais la raison c'est un peu comme comme
hulk buster de l'avenger si vous voulez
un du coup je fais quoi sur mon cas you
[ __ ] j'suis mal à dieu
ok donc nous voilà dans une douce
prairie extrêmement belle nouveauté on a
une chouette
et oui voilà ça c'est ma chouette voyez
c'est finalement un peu comme un drone
en 2015 à la préhistoire c'était une
chouette et grâce à cette chouette jeu
peut repérer les ennemis et les animaux
qui sont aussi viser une médaille alors
on doit trouver la tanière des loups
actuellement pour finalement réussir à
apprivoiser un loup au thé mammouth
est-ce que c'est pas le moment de faire
une énorme bêtise qu'on va vraiment
regretter ils sont gentils hier il veut
et où il veut pas et c'est pas comme ce
connard d'ours hi fi c'est lui qui a
peur ok je marche marche là c'est un
sketch tanière des autres c'est tout
droit alors on va tout droit
il me suis pas comme la soie beth
voulais c'était une boutade il va moins
de chott [ __ ] ça blague pas un amour
là on parle pas de la bourse au lavage
suis désolé mec pour que les fesses mon
dieu alors ça c'est des émissions
baisser des gens voilà qui déjà n'ont
plus d'être quand même rencontre mais
au-delà de ça qu'ils mangent la chaire
d'autres gens essaient de parler à
manger la chair d'autres genres ou
gattaca ouga ouga ouga chacha cas voilà
alors oui la tanière des loups à la fin
allait tout droit à mon avis elle est
par l'unfp faut trouver le boss des
loups c'est un loup blanc la bayanne
grotte ok c'est l'artiste cao cao cao
regarder la coupe et pourquoi au le
loser blanc ni call ok je soupçonne le
loup blanc de se trouver dans cette
grande juste bah c'est pas une grotte
nickel jean-michel squeeze vraiment
efficace dans les jeux vidéo blue glow
oui tu s'il te plaît loup blanc lou bega
lupin excellente blague je me fais
attaquer par abc une blague
alors toi pour rien alors là la nuit va
tomber
je suis passé c'est qu'on va enflammer
nos armes sinon on va se faire défoncer
par une meute de 122 animaux que tu
avais quand vous les choux ce [ __ ]
loup blanc sans plus et fait nuit d'un
calvaire tâche pour hambourg all
beaucoup trop au sérieux la saveur du
tout alors 7 qui est là dans la loue
c'est sûr y est la tempête montre toi
jeune luca era dans cette année rien ni
lui ni souris dini lapin est rien non
non non ils m'ont vu n'en avons pas vu
ou pas vu une preuve patente crevettes
alors toi mon gars un coup de gourdin
dans la salle à faire tout drôle aux
hommes je te brûle la violence amer je
me suis enflammé au ces [ __ ] mais chut
le fun tout à fait le cas pour et prend
feu au maire d'auch qui es-tu peuvent
tout brûler en fait j'ai pas compris qui
veut brûler toute sak game over pour toi
tu es la gagnante
adacore elle s'éteint elle souffle sur
sa peau ça c'est un homme et ça marche
pas comme ça dans la vie pourquoi des
brûlots qu'est ce qui se passe jamais
arrêté aux îles abritent arrive je suis
désolé vraiment i'm sorry like justin
bieber on n'a toujours pas trouvé le
loup blanc [ __ ] ça m'énerve
alors tu peux matin de la haute
évidemment la réponse est non mondiaux
c'est le loup blanc
ils sont tuer le loup blanc trouvé le
chef de meute des loups et apprivoiser
l'eau pour qu'ils se battent à vos côtés
au j'accepte avec grand plaisir
ah ok on va devoir utiliser de l'avion
pour faire des appâts à regarder le loup
blanc était blessé il faut trouver où il
est parti se cacher oc saba il est là
bas enfin après tant de guerres et de
peine je lance en a pas est ce que ça a
marché
oui sur l'auteur bon chien chien soit
millions avec nous s'il te plaît turbo
va bien s'occuper de toi ça marche et ça
marche et ça me joue au qu'il est beau
bordel on va par défaut c'est l'ours
alors la mecque jambette explosion la
gueule ah oui ah oui ah ouais ok là ont
défoncé en une seconde
ce bien mon chien c'est fantastique je
n'attends rien des rues s'illuminent et
illuminé manquerait plus qu'ils fassent
un petit caca dessus et on dirait
vraiment à l'ordre constate notre
village maintenant c'est un refuge pour
les wedges à banias problème un peu qui
nous manque deux pots de serre et de
roseaux pour construire une [ __ ]
d'accord aviv chaussettes du sud sa
crème ou fait cher je pars chez tech je
suis chasseur vous comprenez ça alors je
dois trouver des serbes
ces desserts sa [ __ ] ce loup est
excellent je le mène dans la vraie vie
dès que je fais un truc je l'envoie par
exemple j'ai besoin de manger il va
faire les courses pour moi attend va
jusqu'où la voie jusqu'au bout
elle attendait mais qui sont partis à le
coût de la patate
là
c'est bien mon cher attend lui aussi
rappelé ces scans humiliante
toto garder les os et nous finance c'est
maintenant l'heure de la vengeance
castor au corps tour souhaité us castor
merde holla holla roquet décrit au
[ __ ] mais mais mais mais mais mais
c'est quoi ce bordel ça va être chaud ça
va être chaud ça va être chaud louette -
one way touch boucher mourir et leurs
noms mais mec il est beaucoup trop pour
ce lot et moi je propose qu'on termine
sur ce magnifique joueur de batterie
ça n'a aucune sonorités plaisante et
voilà juste fait face aux far cry ferai
moi je la scène la plus c'est le cas
n'hésitez pas à aller mais comme
d'habitude à écouter voilà tout ce qu'on
va devoir chasser le mammouth chasser la
fièvre attendait puisqu'il a fini de
jouer de la batterie
je crois qu'il écouterait appareils
reste qu il sortait coup il voulait pas
qu'on le regarde alors sauté dans le
prochaine et deux versements regarder
portez vous bien john furlong
oui ça
en cours